this is Startalk here's a personal
question for both of you and it's from
Angela Moroni from Instagram and Angela
says what kind of major challenges did
you personally face to get where you are
today okay so this is this is your own
personal story I mean there's no real
right or wrong answer to this it's not
scientifically based but it is
experientially based is there anything
that you can think of that from a gender
specific standpoint where you you you
ran into some obstacles on your path or
your journey to this point I I think I'm
really lucky in that I didn't face any
major challenges but I think
unfortunately like you know for better
for worse that's one of the reasons that
I'm here as a scientist because I didn't
face major challenges now that is a very
good point the fact that you are where
you are is because you receive the kind
of nurturing and assistance necessary to
put anybody in your position and you
were just able to do it sometimes I kind
of think that yeah and I mean I but I do
know other people have overcome major
challenges and I know that they're like
smarter than me and tougher than me and
like and I know and also thinking about
the fact that so many people that did
face more challenges than me
don't make it even though they want to
that's got to be fixed right I was gonna
say that the real problem is those who
face the challenges and go to hell with
this yeah this is just too much man I
can't you know yeah and that's fair I
mean some of the challenges are just you
know I grew like grew up with like a
house and enough food and things like
that and that's something that you know
a lot of people don't have and it
actually frightens me on a day-to-day
basis like what we could be missing
because not everybody is taken care of
not everybody has the same opportunities
like what geniuses are not even living
you know out of infancy or something
like that because you know we don't take
care of everybody kind of equally across
the planet yeah
is a price to be paid by human capital
in human capital by this disparity
disparity exacts a price upon all
societies so there's a product of
society and summer do you have an actual
I have a quite a similar story to Emily
I think in the sense that I was really
fortunate to have amazing women mentors
at every step almost okay
even though we were collectively still
the minority at every point as far as
gender minority so I first of all I'm
raised by a single mother I'm the only
child she's she's not in technical
science fields at all but she supported
me the entire time in my pursuit of it
one of my mentors in college was the
only tenured female engineering
professor in the department
I actually so I came through engineering
so I have a little winding road story
but I worked in aerospace engineering
and my boss was a woman mm-hm she was
one of the few women grad school my
adviser was a woman also and that was
that was kind of random like in my
particular experience I didn't get to
choose that person I chose a project and
that turned out to be run by one of the
women who had been there since she was
in an undergrad so it's kind of amazing
and then I think personally which may
have slightly been affected by gender
when I was in grad schools when I had
like a major depressive episode and that
was my first encounter with depression
okay and I do think that there was being
a the minority in the group and also
just not being confident enough to seek
out help at various stages and also
share that information in the academic
environment that I was in sort of kept
me back made that take a bigger made me
take a bigger hit due to that okay yeah
all right well you know I love the fact
that them what you both kind of focused
on is that when you get when you get the
proper push and and and assistance it
makes things easier and I say this to
everybody nobody gets anywhere without
help absolutely yeah that's all there is
do it yeah and so the the more help that
is available for anyone the better
you're gonna do at anything so you know
I and just think of it this way when you
look at the NFL and the NBA you would be
so shocked to find how many players have
a family member father uncles somebody
who played professional that
professional sport interesting and
everybody thinks like these guys are
just you know that guy had somebody
mentoring him from the time he was three
years old put a basketball in his hand a
football and say look at the Manning
brothers I mean there's actually three
of them but only to count but the fact
is they're the son of Archie Manning
yeah okay so you know the help thing is
a very big thing is what I'm saying so
that's so that's a really good lesson
too for science in general like science
you know you hear the the myths of the
lone genius and that kind of a thing but
science is a is a community and team
effort and group effort and you can't
get anywhere and especially in grad
school so I used to work on a program
that helped postback students sort of
get prepared for grad school and the
thing that you really have to drill into
them is that you need to ask for help
it's good that's right you should
identify resources outside yourself you
can't do it alone
absolutely so knowing that it could that
even the grad school is a thing like the
grad school is something where you keep
going to school but you get paid to do
it
and so yeah Chuck knives might be going
back to grad school but it's not you
know it's not like you know law school
in med school are kind of more popular
you you have to pay for those and it's a
huge amount of money but graduate school
especially in the sciences is generally
paid for you you know you work but
you're working is teaching or doing
research or something like that you're
not paid a huge amount of money but it's
generally a paid enough to live on and
you're going to school yeah and you're
going to school to get a PhD or to get a
master's degree and this is something
that because it's a relatively small
amount of the population that does it
it's not very well known that it's even
a path right so if you don't already
have a scientist
in your life you might not even know
it's a thing that you can do you don't
know you also don't have to go to grad
school and only become a professor you
can go to grad school and then you know
you can get a PhD in physics and even
you know then work in finance or become
an astronaut or you know work in fashion
all kinds of things right because right
Wow yeah ISM no I'm making it rain
go to grad school ah okay
interesting that too is actually it
counters the leaky pipeline example
because I like to think of it more it's
not that you're losing these people but
you are for some reasons the pipeline is
not encouraging them to go on but some
of them are making these alternative
choices we shouldn't even call
alternative because the idea is that
there's just this huge range of careers
a lot of options at every level people
with astronomy phd's that work for like
Etsy and stitch fix and Netflix and
github and you know all kinds of
software companies and all kinds of
internet companies and things like that
so you can really do all kinds of
different things with a science PhD wow
that's amazing
that's great stuff well there you go
kids stay in school